this morning at 7:00 a.m. Eastern
another stunning announcement
[Music]
good morning breaking news overnight
Matt Lauer has been terminated from NBC
News longtime today's show host Matt
Lauer fired from NBC for alleged
inappropriate sexual behavior in the
workplace and alack the news chairman at
the peacock Network released a statement
this morning that says a complaint was
filed last night by a colleague and
there is reason to believe it wasn't an
isolated incident and now we know it may
not have been in a piece just published
by Variety it's reported that Lauer's
accused of sexual harassment by multiple
women
co-host Savannah Guthrie found out Lauer
was let go this morning and had the
emotional and difficult task of breaking
the news to the world all we can say is
that we are heartbroken I'm heartbroken
from Matt he is my dear dear friend and
my partner and he is beloved by many
many people here and I'm heartbroken for
the brave colleague who came forward to
tell her story and any other women who
have their own stories to tell and we
are grappling with a dilemma that so
many people have faced these past few
weeks how do you reconcile your love for
someone with the revelation that they
have behaved badly and I don't know the
answer to that as painful as it is this
moment in our culture and this change
had to happen
okay so that was Savannah Guthrie former
colleague of mine from Court TV
obviously having an emotional
challenging time because she has a very
close relationship friendship with Matt
Lauer they said she found the
information out this morning Greg even
had to go on and tell everyone I don't
know man I remember the good old days
when it was just FNC and everybody
everybody was making fun of us FNC is
like the first kid on the block who got
chickenpox and all the other classes
left and then it spread and they're all
going holy crap is this good is this
purva get and ever gonna end it seems to
be with Lauer quite pervasive but it's
not just a pattern of abuse it is a
pattern of acquiescence when you when
you're at a company and you make a lot
of money the people around that that
person won't listen to you because he
feels he can do what he wants in a weird
way we are a lot of these people seem
like children
they have to be told how to act because
they've been told yes so many times
throughout their lives they've been told
yes that the idea of somebody saying no
makes no sense to them so they just
bring you into an office and then they
press a button behind their desk so the
door locks I would like to see that
conversation with office services like I
can understand getting a clap on like
clap off but saying I'd like a button
behind my desk to lock the door when I'm
seated so I can have sex with a stranger
it's kind of a hard conversation to have
all right wouldn't be aware of that okay
so Dana here we are back in our old
studio today and what we'll be in here
again what till Friday I guess we're
back in we look good in here though I
think so too
nice lighting so tough seeing her today
for obviously Hoda
for Savannah for a lot of the people
that have you know grown up essentially
and watched the Today Show with Matt
Lauer for you as these revelations have
come come out like the Harvey Weinstein
one was kind of I think the one of the
biggest and then every day though you
could have another story like this just
last week you had to see a CBS's Charlie
Rose and I do think about how all of
these other networks covered Fox News
when we went through our own
difficulties and that's been about a
year now and within the last year one
thing that's different with NBC I
thought from the others so far is that
NBC got ahead of the news coverage I
wondered about that with CBS beacon and
others that you know that these
reporters are working on stories mm-hmm
and with CBS for example the Washington
Post story ran and then the news came
out that they were going to suspend and
then fire Charlie Rose in this case I
could suppose what happened was that
because the young will mainly I don't
know young the woman came forward to the
NBC executives at the same time they
knew that these stories were being
worked on by various publications in New
York Times and others that they went
ahead did their own investigation and
took very decisive action beforehand so
that they actually got to announce the
news NBC announced the news it was a yes
they did a preemptive strike because
they knew the damn of stories was going
to break it was gonna be bad well one of
the suggestions are
they said that they had discovered this
as somebody came forward on Monday but
the reporting is also stating that they
had been aware of complaints and that
newspapers had been working on these
items which they usually will contact a
media relations department if they have
something like this going on to let them
know especially if they want to speak to
people that work there yeah only NBC
News knows how far back the allegations
go and whether they were really decisive
we don't really know that because they
could have known about these things for
a very long time and because of the
avalanche of reporters about to break
something that could have forced their
hand also this woman coming forward but
you know when Savannah Guthrie said what
she said today I think myself and many
people here can understand what she's
saying on the one hand if you work with
someone for many many years and you
admire that person and you know that
person closely you feel very sad for
that person to crash and burn but at the
same time you feel horribly saddened for
the alleged victims of any sort of
sexual harassment or impropriety so it's
a very complicated and complex situation
for everybody when they're involved in
they're working with people that deal
like this this guy made so much money
for NBC News it can't really be
understated this Today Show was the
cornerstone of the network and they made
I think hundreds of millions of dollars
each year in profit profit for this
network and Matt Lauer would was paid
very handsomely I think he just signed a
20 million dollar a year contract and
it's like the New England Patriots
losing Tom Brady it's their franchise
quarterback the the key to the offense
so to speak so that's familiar right
yeah yeah we've been through it other
companies have been through it and now
it's happening to them it's almost like
too big to fail you remember in the
financial crisis when you know these
companies they're doing a lot of bad
things where they're making a lot of
money for the shareholders and then they
crash the system and then they get
bailed out so it perpetuates bad
behavior now people are saying you know
what not too big to fail they're allowed
to you know let bad people go or people
that are accused of doing bad things go
and there
willing to take the hit and start fresh
and I think that's kind of gonna be the
new outlook when you handle these things
start fresh so ya want so the
allegations also that the New York time
was about to release a story that NBC
knew that other stories were about to
drop like Dennis said they kind of got
ahead of this what do you think about
how this was you know handled and in
fact how they handle the communications
with you know Savannah and Hoda today
letting the viewers now I really don't
have much to say about I mean I was
surprised in reading not only about the
button behind the Testament that Greg
mentioned but that they called Matt
Lauer last night before he went to bed
to let him know but they didn't tell
anybody on the staff until this morning
when the Today Show staff was coming in
so my take on this though Kimberly is
that we are at a moment in American
culture I think no question when you
wake up and I mean it was shocking to me
to see I thought it was really they
fired Matt Lauer as Jesse said he's a he
was kind of a central pillar of NBC for
a long time and I agree with you Jesse I
think a lot of companies have to have a
different way of thinking that now you
can't just say revenue and profit is the
be-all and end-all that in fact there's
going to be social consequence and
repercussions as a result of backing
this I mean I I think back to you know
what happened with Anita Hill and the
kind of outpouring
now you have the hashtag me to movement
and on the political front here I'm so
interested in the idea that President
Trump continues to get involved that he
was tweeting on this this morning and
saying you know that Andy liked the
president he says go look at Andy likes
pants I don't even know what that
referred to but apparently something's
there so to me what this boils down to
then is you get a situation in our
country at this moment where you know in
the political sport that's going on you
have Republicans saying oh look the
Liberals the Democrats they don't apply
the same standard they're people that
they impose on a president Trump or on a
Roy Moore down in Alabama who by the way
is now apparently back in the lead in
the polls in his Alabama Senate race and
then you see NBC which is always
positive as the Left take such immediate
action there's more pressure now on
Conyers to resign not really I think
there is
GBC pulled it back to them no no no I'm
talking about overall and by the way
inside the CBC there is pressure you
don't want to exactly show face to
people who are not your friends but I
think that there's no question Conyers
is under pressure I don't think that
this is a political story by any means I
think this is of cultural significance
there is no due process right now and so
we are talking about a sea change people
keep talking about a sea change but it
also could be a panic when the entry for
allegations becomes lower and there's no
investigation there's no questioning by
law enforcement no timeframe to allow
and accuse to try to defend themselves
so the workplace and the surrounding
universe of public opinion is operating
now like a college campus on college
campuses administrators could adjudicate
an assault case that's what's happening
that we're adjudicating that blog
forcement now if somebody accuses you of
assault which is what we're hearing here
with Matt Lauer so the law should be
involved time for Imanol yeah however it
happened in Sochi so it's hard to do
that because it's in another it's in
another country but the fact it's the
common bond in these cases in the media
in politics and in Indus no due process
and it we have to we have to worry not
just about women but about men because
these are your brothers and your sons
you know your sibling you're either your
sibling so your father's or your
grandfather's you have to somehow create
a process for these people to answer not
send me the way Matt Lauer the way this
reads the man's a creep but a lot of
people might not be creepy why do you
think he didn't get due process well I
think that I maybe he didn't have enough
time to know I think that they probably
did ask Matt Lauer they said they
conducted an intense investigation over
a 36 hour period right I can't imagine
that they didn't go to Lauer now the
lawyer for the woman who made the
charges is very pleased and says that
clearly NBC they're fighting there
definitely I think there's something but
I think that the key here in this
discussion about this cultural moment
the reckoning see change however you
want to refer to it is that previously
the advertisers would not have
say a thing they would have said well
this is a popular show that's that's for
someone else to decide in this cultural
moment the advertisers much like the
voters down in Alabama is courting the
president are gonna have their say but I
want to know everything then I want to
know everything about what's going on I
want to know the specific elements in
every case it's like drug overdoses you
benefit from knowing precisely how
people died through the ingredients that
you have in every case is important
because that discerns a difference
between a panic and a sea-change
confidence yeah and speaking of panic we
were just mentioning this when we were
in the green room so the pendulum swings
the other way now and unfairly or
unfairly women can then be unfairly
punished because men are now so scared
of rightly or wrongly being alone with a
woman in the office going on a golf trip
a corporate golf trip an excursion
anything where you're alone with someone
who you work with there's now a climate
of fear and you don't want women
unfairly punished and not included in
meetings or in you know sessions where
you're kicking around ideas because of
the fear of some sort of unfair
retaliation I don't think it's going to
happen that way beautiful to say that
now you know can we go out for drinks
what's gonna happen III fear that that's
going to happen I don't think it will
but isn't that the pen through the what
the pence rule yeah never be alone well
you know he was mocked for the pence
roll a lot of people are wishing they
but you don't want the pence rule
I don't think chilling effect so then
women are deprived of opportunity
otherwise have been included on and then
otherwise in an abundance of caution and
fear and paranoia for something being
wrong because there isn't perhaps due
process and an allegation could be
enough to blow you out or an allegation
could be investigated you find the
evidence of it that supports it but
right now we're just it's such an estate
of flux Dana that there's everything is
kind of piled in together and it's tough
to kind of sort it out just to bring it
back to this in particular so you had a
Matt Lauer and Charlie Rose just for
example they were and also Mark Halperin
you know commenting on things about then
that happened here at the network if we
were the first one with the fresh
chicken pox okay so then they're
covering these stories and you think
about what happened last week when Al
Franken gave his non-apology apology and
it gets the question would you have what
would you have thought two weeks ago and
he said there's never it never would
have occurred to me and I have to wonder
when they were actually doing the
commentary or interviews about what was
happening at Fox News if internally that
they had any idea what that their
behavior was going to come back to haunt
them and I it might be one thing that's
weird culturally at this moment is do
men in positions of power have to
rethink what they've been doing if they
thought it was okay before I remember
sitting at a bar in Cleveland you were
sitting over there everybody and Matt
Lauer was sitting right there and all he
kept doing was asking me about Ailes
constantly asking about Ailes and I'm
going like this is not the right place
to talk about this stuff Ailes hadn't
been gone yet it was the day before and
it was just like I don't know or what
about his interview with O'Reilly yeah
the what he said the top man doesn't go
or something like that no you know
something about how you ask questions or
you know exercising power over your
subordinates yes